foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
calls coming up Louis Riddick one of our
favorites college football analysts and
ESPN NFL analyst and Lewis will be with
Matt Berry the call Virginia Georgia
Tech that'll be Thursday on the
mothership at seven Eastern Louis thanks
for joining us let me start with the
analytical part of looking at the Denver
Broncos offense what exactly if you were
going to say to Russell Wilson
here's the problem or here's here's the
solution but what would you do in an
advisory role
yeah you know I think for us I think you
have to
one stop trying to be perfect
to
just kind of play your game in the style
and the manner in which got you to the
level that you're at as far as people
regarding you
that's one of the best overall play
makers all scheduled Playmakers really
that the league has seen in the past 10
years at the very least now explain by
being perfect well I I guess it's like
this
um
Russ is probably at his very very best
outside of structure and every
quarterback I can I think constantly
hears win from the pocket went from the
pocket went from the pocket stay in the
pocket make sure you go through
progression stay in the pocket at all
costs and and when Russ tries to do that
I think it limits
his game and limits his creativity and
limits his ability to make explosive
plays and kind of make up for
for maybe some of the limitations that
whatever offense that he is in has right
now the limitations that his offense has
in Denver
is consistent past protection obviously
a Dependable Run game especially after
the injuries that they've had at the
running back position
so I think he's almost forced now to be
kind of become
and I don't mean this in a derogatory
way at all but kind of like school yard
backyard rust where he's going to have
to
extend and make plays and go off
schedule probably even more so now
because he just can't sit in the pocket
anyway
so I think for him I think he just needs
to really and I mean really just cut it
Loose do not listen to anything in
regards to trying to be something that
you're not just be who you are and who
you've been at your very best which is
when you are just creating and making
things happen that's when you're at your
best we've criticized them for in the
past saying that he has sometimes made
things too hard on him maybe taking
unnecessary sex maybe Miss some uh short
and intermediate check Downs that could
have been just as fruitful as the big
bomb that he is going uh after in the
long term but I think right now that's
what he he's going to have he's going to
need to do this wide receiver core
you've heard numerous different people
talk about the fact that they are
underperforming not the most disciplined
route Runners not necessarily in the
area in the spots that this offense
would want them to be as far as their
you know their spacing route precision
those are the kind of things that you
would probably expect though when you
have a bunch of young guys trying to
learn a new offense
um that really you know in terms of the
leaks setting it up in the off season
for you to have enough time to get to
know one another it really doesn't work
to your advantage I mean a lot a lot of
times there just isn't enough time and I
know quarterbacks get together with wide
receivers in the off season and have
throwing camps and you know invite them
to their homes maybe go to some warm
weather climate and try to build some
chemistry for a week or two but
look it just doesn't really work that
way it doesn't doesn't come together
that fast we're seeing that around the
league that
teams that or brother players and teams
that kind of de-emphasize the off season
once the regular season starts they're
slow starters and then you know we hear
about teams having to use the first
month of the season that's going to be
an extended form of training camp and
when you have a new coaching staff and a
new quarterback who's trying to get to
learn new wide receivers there's going
to be some bumps in the road in the best
case
and then when you have a worst case
scenario where your offensive line isn't
playing up the par you don't have a
really solid running game the wide
receivers are young they're not always
the greatest route Runners although they
are very good athletes and talented
individuals this is what you're going to
come up with this is what's going to
wind up happening and then here here's
the cherry on the top as far as Russ's
situation is concerned
you have a head coach
who clearly to put it mildly is very
green when it comes to overall
game management roster management maybe
even player management as far as taking
control of this thing and not letting it
get off the rails in the court in the
middle of a game
so that's why now Denver anointed by
many in all season as being maybe one of
the one of the favorites in the west
despite the fact that Patrick Mahomes
has ruled over that division like Lord
Vader for years now
I think it meant people are having to
walk that back and go and maybe I didn't
take into consideration that this is a
new quarterback rookie head coach young
wide receivers a lot of things a lot of
moving Parts here and
this is what you get when that happens
and um
do we do we know
who the Chargers are right now
I think
from a personal perspective Dan yeah we
do
we know that Justin Herbert is special
and unique we know that Mike Williams is
special unique we know that Keenan Allen
is one of the unsung heroes or rather I
shouldn't say Heroes he's one of The
Unsung route runners in just productive
overall wide receivers that the game has
seen in the past six seven years we know
those things and we know that Austin
Eckler is a stud
um
so we know that they're talented
on both sides of the ball that they have
talented people at key positions
what we don't know
is
in the biggest of moments
how will Brandon Staley manage the game
will he manage it objectively off of a
probability slash analytics sheet will
he go with his gut his football
intuition
will it jive with common sense in those
critical moments especially when you're
going to be matched up against in your
division in particular
one of the most respected coaches in the
history of the NFL and Andy Reid are you
going to make the critical decisions
that will be able to one-up a guy like
Andy Reid we don't know those things yet
because they haven't proven those things
yet but we know one through 53 that when
these guys are healthy and obviously
they've suffered some some big time
losses with Rashawn Slater
um but now with um Joey being hurt right
now I mean it's both I mean it's
I think there's a lot more questions
still than answers although they are a
team that a lot of people love to get
behind and say this is a very very
talented team but we but they ask the
same question you just asked but we just
don't know who they're going to be when
it matters the most and I don't think we
still know that answer how nervous would
you be if you're a Packer fan right now
extremely extremely how did this happen
how did this happen I think it starts
obviously a lot of the problems that
start that you see crop up during the
season especially early in the early
part of the Season really started in the
off season I think the uncertainty
surrounding Aaron's situation how it
trickled down to the decision that
Devonte Adams made to leave Aaron not
necessarily being around this off season
around those young wide receivers see
this is what I'm talking about where you
have a limited limited amount of time
you know in a in a really structured
environment at the facility to work with
players and get to know one another and
develop chemistry so as it is as
mandated by the CBA when you then don't
even do that
but then you have a bunch of young wide
receivers and you lost one of the most
prolific most talented wide receivers in
the NFL and he just walks out the door
now you're trying to bring this new
group together and you're not around as
the quarterback
there's just no way there's no way that
in a
in a mandatory mini camp setting and
then in a few training camp practices
where then you're then not even dressing
and playing full speed during games and
I don't care how many joint practices
you do they're nothing like games
it's still different it's still
different because it's not scripted and
it's a game in a stadium with fans and
you have a different uniform on and it
feels different and the pressures are
it's just it's all different I don't
care if it's preseason or regular season
it's different than what a joint
practice is when you don't partake in
all that stuff
if you're not familiar with one another
you're gonna have bumps in the road man
and I had a problem with Rogers not
getting together with these receivers
that's right like like played just a
couple of get into a preseason game and
help them understand the magnitude of
hey you don't you don't replace Devonte
Adams or you don't collectively we do so
I did have a problem with that I I did
too I did too but see many excused Aaron
because he's Aaron and I get that on the
surface this guy's
a prodigy a savant a one of one one of
the guys who many people deem as maybe
the most talented pure passer
in the history of the NFL because he can
do things with the way he throws the
football and the positions he can get
himself in and still deliver the
football accurately that you've never
seen anyone be able to do and that's
great for him
that's great for him
but it's like you know it's like the
reason the reason why some great players
don't ever become coaches is because
they ask they expect players to be able
to do the things that they were able to
do and they can't and they can't really
communicate it to them so they don't
ever become coaches well Aaron is now
maybe expecting some of these wide
receivers to do things that Devonte was
able to do and have the same kind of
chemistry he was able to have with Jordy
Nelson back in the day
but they can't they just can't do that
especially if they don't have the
exposure to him in terms of live reps
that those guys accumulated over years
and years and that's not to say that
Aaron has ridiculous expectations of
these guys because he's spoken about the
fact that I can't expect them to be
where those guys were and when we were
clicking on all cylinders but does it
now know that then be there in off
season does it become even more evident
that the Packers have to go get obj
I don't
you know as far as his experience OJ I
mean obj's play-making ability he says
he has a good relationship with Aaron
yeah on the surface then it makes it
looks like it makes sense but remember
when he went to LA
there was kind of a breaking in period
between him and Matthew Stafford between
him and Cooper cup between him and the
offense overall until it really started
going
and I don't know I mean and he's still
not healthy I mean we don't know where
he's at so it's like
man does that will be too little too
late and then there's other things going
on with that team anyway like
as this offensive line has gotten
healthier and players have returned like
Elton Jenkins gets healthier David
baktiari Gets healthier it still doesn't
matter it's not paying the dividends
that you would expect it to I mean the
Jets took him apart from a physicality
standpoint and that's I would never call
the Packers soft and I've heard some
people say that about how they played
yet um this past Sunday I would never
call them that but they did get whipped
man they look like they were like moving
around in this kind of haze like hey you
know what's going on devante's not here
we can't throw the ball when the way
we're used to you know what's going on
does anybody know what the problem is
it's like yeah you got to do the problem
right now and then on defense I mean
they're top 10 in cap dollars allocated
to defensive side of the football NFL
and they're just getting drug
there's a big problem there right we're
talking to Louis Riddick of the
mothership he'll be on the call with
Matt Berry uh Virginia Georgia Tech
Thursday seven Eastern on ESPN
you had the uh the Cooper Rush
experiment and now Dak comes back
give me what you think the game plan
will be with Doc and is that different
than what the game plan should be with
Dak Prescott
I think it should be exactly the same as
far as
philosophically how you decide to attack
opponents meaning
unless Lino and Tony Pollard and Zeke
let's continue to get them keep them
going let's continue to rotate them but
the same blueprint you had for Cooper
Rush yeah you're going to do the same
with Dak Prescott
I am and I'll tell you and I'll tell you
why because complimentary football is
what got them to where they are it's
good which which
um which is in the National media
Spotlight week after week for winning
games that's ultimately well what they
care about and what they need to be
focused on but here here's here's the
kicker with Dex see what that can do
that Cooper Rush can't do is he can make
the
special throw
maybe the special
pre-snap check audible because he has
been out on the field more times than
and taking more reps than Cooper Rush
that gets them into perfect play that
maybe Cooper couldn't
Jack has seen more looks seen more
precious seen more third down defenses
see more Red Zone two minute defenses to
where
he can make that read quicker when it
comes time to throw the football and and
get the football where it needs to be
accurately then Cooper could so he's
taking that blueprint but he's
accentuating it because he's just simply
a better player
and that's all you need him to do you
don't need to kind of all of a sudden
flip the Run pass ratio and all of a
sudden be like well we're paying back
this much money so now we throw we don't
need to do that we don't need to just do
what you're doing and then let him take
it to another level simply because he's
a better player and I think if they do
that and then you know what as a matter
of fact Dan I think they have to do that
especially initially because you can't
expect that
after this kind of layoff
and no matter what he says whatever any
other any player says when you've been
off that long and you're dealing with an
injury that that directly affects your
performance I mean it's that's throwing
thumb
he's going to have some question in his
mind until he proves to himself okay it
is good in a game setting not in
practice not throwing balls off to the
side with the trainer but in this game
when Brandon Graham is chasing me down I
can throw this rock and put it where I
need to put it
and I don't even think about it there's
going to be an acclimation period so I
think you definitely need to stick with
the blueprint that they've been using
it's been working yeah hell almost
brought him back against Philly
in the final 30 seconds who is more
threatening in the long term this season
the Jets of the Giants
I've been asked this question a couple
times man and I'm all over both of these
teams I would say in the long term
in the long term you generally think
that Talent wins out right Talent wins
out although character can overcome a
lot of deficiencies and that's what's
happening with the Giants character is
overcoming and coaching and culture is
winning not to say that they don't have
good players but that's what's driving
the bus there if the Jets they have the
same things with Robert has some of the
same things going on as far as coaching
and chemistry but they are a very very
talented young football team
in the long run
as long as they don't somehow some way
have some have some kind of chemistry
and or culture issue crop up there which
you know sometimes we come to expect
with the Jets because they're the Jets
they from a talent standpoint
they have got it going man I would bet
on the talent in the long run because
that's what history says I should do
so I'll go with them but
they ball right now you have to you have
to give him the coach of the year you
have to at right now right now if you
had to pick a coach what he's done with
Daniel Jones obviously he's not the one
who's keeping saquan Barkley healthy but
what is going on with saquon Barkley the
lack of weapons they have on the
perimeter and they're still able to move
the football and score points
and Wink Martindale may be assistant
coach of the year right now considering
how he leaves Baltimore Baltimore is
suffering dramatically drastically on
defense and he's got this group of
players in New York
playing their rear ends off
just so many good things happening for
the Giants right now it's it's got to be
great to be a Giants fan but the Jets
they're not the same old Jets those days
I believe are long gone Robert Salas
said I'm keeping receipts on people who
are talking crap about me here early in
the season and saying we're the same old
Jets when the time comes and this thing
turns I'ma pull them out it's almost
time it's early in the season I don't
know if he wants to pull him out yet
but I have a feeling he's straightening
them out and organizing him on his desk
and saying I'm gonna get this guy first
and this guy then and this because that
team has turned the corner okay if there
was a fight with all of the head coaches
in the NFL who's is is Robert Sala a
number one seed
yeah yeah yeah he is he is he's up there
man I Robert's not just all bravado the
guy's kind of put together man he's up
there he's up there you know I'm trying
to think right now like who
uh I would not oh you never mess with
wrestlers okay ever brabel everybody
knows that on the street brabel and Sean
McDermott Sean McDermott was a very good
wrestler as a matter of fact he has said
numerous times that wrestling is his
first love
that was his sport you don't mess with
wrestlers ever
ever I don't know you know Brandon
Staley and Zach Taylor may not scare me
too much like analytically they would be
approaching the fight in a different way
than everybody else you know who else
would have been a good you know who else
who could have rumbled like say 10 years
ago Big Red Man
Andy Reid 10 years ago yeah yeah look
I'm just telling you I played
racquetball with this man a few times
when we were in Philly and run into him
accidentally a few times and a few times
he's hit me I'm telling you he's a brick
fricking wall
and I mean I mean he looks like a brick
wallet but I'm just telling you he has
he's tough as hell tough as hell
10 years ago though before I think he
had his knee replaced didn't he would
Gruden have scared you no
Don just walks around with his chest
Daddy
are you kidding me he would he used to
walk around with a football in his
letter jacket on the campus of the
University of Dayton that still doesn't
mean you can fight no no he couldn't
play but he did have it yeah you know
you know who else you know who else
would give you a run
would be uh would be John Harbaugh
he could scrap too how about Ron Rivera
maybe 10 years ago yeah yeah yeah look
he played what's up oh no no we're
missing we're missing the number one
seed who
Dan Campbell
hmm
yeah are you kidding me Lewis he's gonna
bite you he's gonna you know what you
know he's gonna take whatever it takes
Dan Campbell will he'll die in battle
Yeah well yeah I mean that's what he
says
that's what he says you know there's a
lot of people who talk I'm not say I'm
not every question I'm not gonna
question Dan Campbell's talk I think you
just did no no I didn't yeah you did
I'm not questioning his toughness man
anybody get up get a hold of Dan
Campbell tell him Lewis is questioning
his toughness okay I'll tell you this
there is a guy on his staff
there is there are some coaches on his
staff yeah but we're not talking about
that yeah I know that but we're Stanley
yeah I know Deuce deuce would be I
wouldn't mess with Deuce daily
nope you know what you guys should do on
NFL Live or you know total breakdown on
the toughest head coaches in the NFL and
just have like you know the octagon and
then tail the tape
that would be kind of fun um all right I
gotta run uh all right have fun Thursday
night always great thank you for uh
spending some time of course man that's
Louis Riddick Mothership be on the call
of Virginia Georgia Tech on Thursday
night 7 30.